here
wait
go
their season was innocent
but one day everything changed
forever you have 24 hours to play me if
you want to see your girl again don't
listen to him
he's lying
he's got trash who is that when i find
you i'm going to beat you so hard i want
to beat you so hard
no i'm going to beat you so hard
i'm going to beat you so hard you have
no idea how hard i'm going to beat you
do i need to get ready dude you got to
shut up
we're going to need some playmakers
go ahead and work work it like a boss
dave franco as blade johnson christopher
mintz plus as janet rob gronkowski as
have top julio jones as trick motobot go
ahead
and introducing colin kaepernick as al
pacino from scent of a woman
this fall
the play makers unite i've got to beat
him and madden to get her back
coach i need you dad we're gonna need
you to train him i'm not your father man
he's not your father
that's what i'm talking about
it's ajv it's man it's bad
then why and why
we got a [ __ ]
we got company
so
you gotta elevate
now you're getting it
he's here
baby
dad
right on time
i told you our plan would work
let's play
this
is for my dad
what the hell man we were just about to
play what are you doing
nfl 16 ready for everyone ea sports in
the game
buy xbox one and get mad in nfl 16.